ten things I wish I'd known as a
professional property investor and
businessman ten years ago
later listen on actually a wedding I've
just nipped out so my wife might come
and drag me any minute so I'm gonna try
and keep is pretty quick but it I was
advising my 10 year younger self if I
had a beach Inc with my 10 years younger
self what would I say to my tenure
younger self and these are the things
that I would say I would take number one
good debt is your friend
embrace it one of the things that we
learn when we grow up is debt is bad and
thank God I got into debt when I was a
teenager and and borrowed we've got a
mortgage I borrowed money from people to
put into property I borrowed money from
people to put into my own education
thank God that I did that because but
the thing is here's the thing at the
time I didn't know how much of a good
thing that was at the time I was like
this is a bit risk I remember buying a
house if none of my money I got an 80%
mortgage and 20% I bought from my
grandma and I remember thinking oh my
goodness she offered to give me more
money and I was like and I was like my
heart was beating fast five years later
that property shut up in value and the
cash flow but more than the cash flow
the capital appreciation I made from
that deal I thought damn I wish I'd
borrowed more money because I was scared
of debt because I didn't understand the
difference between good and bad a good
debt is your best friend that's the
first thing on a sensor don't be afraid
of it number two is most deal saucers
suck the only property deals that I've
lost money on are ones I've paid someone
else to find for me so most deal sources
sucked warning number three I'm
qualified to make a decision 10 year
younger Samuel EADS you qualified to
make a decision when I was like 20 and I
was going around looking at houses I
didn't trust myself to make a decision
or whether I should buy the house or not
so I'd have to go to viewings with a
proper adult or a builder or someone
like that because I didn't trust myself
and and and now what I would say is
listen man trust yourself
get the professional surveys done and
the professional after you've gone
through the house but feel free to put
offers forward without having a battle
with you like just trust yourself you'll
qualified to make a decision number four
document everything document everything
I really regret that I didn't start
documenting and filming my property
journey those first few years because
firstly is when you document your
journey people get to people see it but
you put it when you put yourself out
there when you document it and you put
it out there people see it and when
people know who you are it's much easier
to do business because you can do joint
ventures you can raise finance people
want to it's just how can you do
business if people don't know who you
are property business is the people
business so document everything for that
reason but also I love looking back on
myself and seeing how much I've improved
I cringe looking back at some of the
videos that I did five years ago I'm
like oh my goodness so so so document it
so you can track your personal
development but also you want to
document everything so you can see the
thickness sometimes you think oh this
house is doing really well but then we
unless you document it and you and you
actually have the figures oh wow this is
actually our document over there this is
actually how it's done you don't know if
it's doing good or not it's just you
know you've got a document everything
put yourself out there number five
selling is everything and selling is a
learnable skill I didn't realize that I
thought as a property investor I needed
to be good at property investing not
knowing that actually selling is the key
ingredient what I mean by selling
selling is what just making it
influencing people making it easy to be
able to do business with you that
selling and when you're dealing with
tenants and investors and landlords and
agents and you tell you with people and
you've got to be able to sell and
selling is something that's learn about
so I didn't realize online lost a lot of
deals by selling myself short and if I
was supposed to go back ten years I
would be learning how to sell I wouldn't
believe it now number six and I hope
you're enjoying these so far if you are
by the way don't forget to just smash
that like button below that I'd really
appreciate that
number six is you cannot please
everybody I mean we're not when I was
young and I was starting out I used to
lose sleep over it when tenants were
upset with me but the thing is you
cannot
please everybody 100% of people 100% of
the time you just can't and if you're
everybody's cup of tea then you would be
a mug so like an example of this would
be if I down a property for four five
years and I HMO and I'd go in and I'd
say guys we're gonna do a reefer but
we're gonna put a new kitchen new
bathroom we're going to spend five
thousand pounds left in the house and
we're gonna put the rents up by twenty
five pound a month fair some tenants
would love it yes thank you I was about
to move out but I'm so glad
and yet the rent review makes sense and
if you're putting but then others will
be like I like it the way it is you just
can't please everybody even when I do
youtube videos some people will say you
know I hate it when you when you say
this alright I don't like this video the
people say I love that but you just
can't please everybody so what I'll say
to my younger self is don't try and
please everybody just do you and as long
as you're acting ethically and you're
helping people and you're sleeping well
at night and you're making money you're
adding value just don't care anybody
thinks number seven a bad tenant is
worse than no tenant Jesus in the early
days I would sometimes have no tenant
and I'd be like worried oh my gosh I'm
out of town in three weeks I'm losing
money on this house so I would put
someone in there that I knew wasn't a
great tenant but I just wanted rent
never ends well the only thing worse
than no tenant is a bad tenant you just
don't want it you just don't want it
because then they won't pay the rent and
then they'll trash the place as well
like really important in a break
professionals do lie just because an
estate agent says that this is the value
does not mean that this is the value
just because something's printed in a
book does not mean that it's fact you
know professional people do lie a lot of
people have an agenda you just need to
figure out what their agenda is don't be
a follower of one person but be a
student of many so what I would say is
rather than just just Oh enough what
someone said do your own research and
trust your own intuition and make up
your own mind number nine you Samuel
leaves 19 years old you're gonna be
hated not nice to say I wouldn't enjoy
saying that to my 10 year younger self
but I didn't expect people to hate on me
and but here's the thing there would be
no such thing as light if there wasn't
darkness
there's no such thing as fans and people
that love you if there's not some people
but hate you so for every one hater
you've helped 200 just get over and
expect it again it's a little bit
similar to the companies everybody but
when you're in business sometimes people
are going to be upset with you sometimes
you're gonna have to make tough
decisions if you if you've got staff
sometimes you're gonna have to fire
people or you're gonna have to interview
people and say no sorry you're not the
right person sometimes you are gonna
have to evict bad tenants if they're not
paying their rent and you're gonna feel
really bad about it and they're gonna
end up hating you and giving you
horrible letters it's just gonna happen
it's not gonna happen if you have ten
tenants but if you have a hundred
tenants or a thousand tenants some of
them aren't there like you you put
yourself out there on YouTube you have
some people that don't like it so if
you're going to grow big and which I
have done just expect that some people
I'm gonna like yet I don't know why some
people that maybe it's because they're
jealous maybe some people are trying to
protect you so they're being may sayers
maybe some people have got a right not
to like you but it's just gonna happen
but if you're helping a lot of people
you're making a lot of money adding a
lot of value expect that you will also
be take it number 10 and this is
arguably the most important thing that I
would say to my tenure in the sales is
hey you are gonna be successful you're
gonna be successful like when I was
starting out I never thinking oh I hope
I'm successful I hope this works
listen being rich being successful is a
choice not a destiny as long as you take
the proper appropriate steps get the
appropriate training it's just gonna
happen it's like if you get in a car and
drive and follow us and you're gonna get
to the destination as long as you put
the right destination which is the
destination for financial freedom and
then take the right steps and go on the
right journey it's just gonna happen
it's a choice so don't feel like I hope
this works for me I hope if someone
gives me a break give yourself a break
you you know you can do so I think those
will probably summarize the 10 things
that I wish I'd learned 10 years ago 10
things that are going to top my 10 year
younger self let me know what you think
guys please do drop your comments below
don't forget to subscribe if you watch
my videos and you're not subscribed geez
I want to find you and I'm going to
punch you in the throat if you don't
spend a couple of days learning about
property and getting your financial
freedom formula put in place for you
and come on down to the property
investors crash course I'm gonna put a
link somewhere in the description and
you can come on down for free two days
to learn about property guys thank you
so much and I'm gonna get back in the
wedding and going enjoy some food see
you later
[Music]